you remember that radical transgender
group that responded to the shooting in
Nashville by mourning the death of the
shooter and insinuating that the real
victims of the shooting were the
transgender identifying people well
that's pretty much the White House
position one of the things that we saw
during the midterm elections is that
people don't want their freedoms to be
to fight for their freedoms
and so it is shameful it is disturbing
and our hearts go out to uh those the
trans Community as they are under attack
right now the trans Community that's
what's up our hearts go out to the trans
Community under attack after a
transgender attack on little kids at a
Christian School where we still haven't
seen the manifesto but what the chief of
police suggested was that gender
ideology played a pretty big role in the
attack the real victims the real victims